Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show. I am once again, and maybe for the
last time in quite a while Jesse Dallimore
sitting in for David Pakman while he is out,
hopefully resting and relaxing and
having a good time with the family.
I don't know how many times I've said this, and it
gets a little old having to say it all the time.
But Republicans are projection artists. They point
the finger and make accusations about things that
they themselves are guilty of. Especially
related to voter fraud and election fraud.
How many times have they they saber rattled
and freaked out about the widespread issue
of voter fraud. And then when you hear about
cases of individual voter fraud that happen,
it's always a Republican or some
husband who votes for his dead wife for.
Some politician whose wife is voting for him
multiple times, just over and over and over and
over again. They out themselves as guilty of the
same thing they're accusing everyone else of. And
this is really just a lie. It's this is this is
salve for for my wounds. This is this is vitamin
for me. Kerry Lake now likely committed a felony
breaking election laws in Arizona by tweeting out
a picture of voter signatures. This woman who's
been making the rounds like every other day,
it seems like she's at Mar a Lago cozying up to
Donald Trump, kissing the ass of Donald Trump,
promoting him as this great savior. She's
talked about herself as Donald Trump in a dress.
Not far off. I'm going to read a little
bit from this headline from this local
Arizona NBC affiliate. The title of which is
looks Like a felony. Elections expert says
Carrie Lake may have gone too far by tweeting
voter signatures. And then and then a little
statement from Oann and Trump lawyer Elina
Harber, who is just about as I mean, look,
if you're ever in a situation where you're in need
of legal representation, please do not seek out
someone who is as unprofessional and harebrained
as Elina Harbor for the ex-president of the
United States of America. To have this woman
representing him on TV and in courtrooms is just
crazy. So we'll start with the headline here. And
the a little bit from this article looks like a
felony. Elections expert says Kari Lake may have
gone too far by tweeting voter signatures. For
almost three months, Carrie Blake has refused
to accept her defeat in the Arizona's governor
race. But now Lake may have gone too far with the
tweet. Again, the parallels between she and Trump
are just rich, that she's in trouble now because
of a tweet. Arizona's top election officer,
Democratic Secretary of State Adrian Fontana, has
asked Democratic Attorney General Chris Mayes to
investigate whether Lake broke the law by posting
16 voter signatures in an image She tweeted last
week, quote, Arizona statute is very clear about
when and where a voter signature can be shared or
replicated or reproduced or put online or
used in social media, said Tammy Patrick,
chief executive for programs at the National
Association of Election Administrators and a
former former Maricopa County elections official.
Quote, The answer to all of those things basically
is never and not, and it can't be. With very few
exceptions. Patrick's opinion of the lake tweet.
When I read the law, it looks to me like
that's a felony under Arizona law. Quote,
The records containing voter signatures shall
not be accessible or reproduced by any person
other than the voter, a violation of the law as a
class six felony that could carry jail time. And
then a statement from the secretary of state here
It is my responsibility to protect Arizona voters,
Bonta said in a statement. In keeping with
my duties, I have referred this matter to the
attorney general. And then here, as promised,
just just a put just get it right into your
veins. Eleanor Hall, Donald Trump's attorney,
making an appearance on the way in and just
giving her her legal opinion about the matter.
Speaker 2: Leak included a graphic with 16 voter
signatures on the tweet font as cited in Arizona
statutes, saying that voter signatures, quote,
shall not be accessible or reproduced by any
person other than the voter. Bob dismissed the
letter, labeling it as an intimidation tactic.
Speaker 3: I think this is a drastic attempt on
the part of Democrats who have forced their way
into office against the will of many voters who
have very serious concerns about the election
in Arizona. And I think this is an intimidation
technique. You would think that they would do
a simple cease and desist letter to carry teams
saying, Hey, can you please take that down off
of social media? We're concerned about privacy
rights. But they went straight to requesting the
newly installed Democrat attorney general to look
into criminal charges against Kari Lake or her
her social media team for this. I mean, talk about
escalating something extraordinarily quickly.
Speaker 1: So one that's not Olina Harbor.
That's Kristina Bob, that's
another Trump lawyer, too.
She's asking for a cease and desist. Why didn't
they just say, hey, stop felony quick, quit
committing felonies? Stop the felonious activity
and you'll be okay? You already tweeted it. You
already put it out there. There have already been
screenshots and these tweets and all of the shares
that take place. You committed the felony. You
don't get to take back. You don't get a redo.
When it's a classic felony that carries with it
possible jail time. But leave it to a Trump lawyer
to make excuses for someone in power. It is just
one more case of Republican projection, one more
case of Republican disregard for the law, all
while attempting to act like they are the party
of law and order and blue lives matter and back
the blue and, you know, just follow the law. It's.
All a bit much. Listen, I want to say thank
you for joining me this week while I subbed
for David. It has been a good time getting to
interact with some of you in the comments and
I appreciate you very much. If you would
like to stick with me, you can subscribe
to my YouTube channel Jessy Dallimore or
find me on social media. I am at Dallimore
just about everywhere. You can also check out my
twice weekly weekly podcast called I Doubt It,
co-hosted by myself and the lovely, talented and
scholarly Bryony Page. We'd love to see you back.